and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bum
tonight's review activity greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
what was it oh it's okay it's just a
spoilers dears his film series called
Paranormal Activity and they've made an
entire film series out of moving a door
and telling us that it's scary
alright the door moved that's scary but
this time around they've done something
completely different
ruddiness little pony to tell us that
the door moved and it's scary all right
little boy me the door move but who is
this little boy well he used to live
next door to this family who also can't
stop filming everything that goes on in
their lives but unfortunately the little
boy's mother is taken to the hospital so
the friend was like me just take care of
this little point because he has nobody
used to care for him yeah do you think
that's a little weird
no do you even know the mother no could
the police who apparently found the
mother have put the boy in more
specialized care no boy's name is Ravi
and he's like I just your everyday
standard little boy you look like a
creepy spawn of Satan don't talk about
father that way so the boy likes to play
with the family Sun and the Sun is like
look when I turn on the night vision
with the Kinect I can see all these
little dark why is that interesting
because not only will create some creepy
skiers we can also get a sponsor out of
it toy marketing in these movies is the
real monster oh but we're in this movie
your father and I are going to deny you
every single chance we get now if you'll
excuse me we're going to do the benign
tango come dirty guy so Ravi is trying
to convince the son that he actually has
a different name your name is hunter who
take you take your name to a dick you
take your name is hunter actually hold
yourselves good okay I'm hunter and then
something really creepy happens in the
kitchen the mother's knife flies up and
we don't see it for a while
oh yeah what is he gonna try
it's gonna be when somebody's looking
over there Philippe's mother finally
comes home
but it's candy from the other Marie's
wait how does that make sense
Katie originally left with Hunter now
she has another kid and Hunter got
adopted by another family
when did she lose Hunter that doesn't
seem like a woman who could easily lose
her kid if anyone tried to take her kid
away she'd be like Photoshop face but
you okay she eventually gets Robbie back
and they bring the hunter kid with him
so she sneaks into the house where Katie
sees or tries to eat her head so she
tries to bring hunter with her but he
won't come and when she turns around
what they're CC women Katie grabs the
girl is like all we wanted was a hog boy
those trailers were right all the
Paranormal Activity movies have been
building up to this another build up for
another sequel but at least so many
questions have finally been answered
like where did Katie get that Robbie kid
why is it only a Google window were
possessed at the end
how did Katie lose hunter in the first
place oh wait those are dancers are
freaking twice times there's more
questions and these movies in the game
so maybe this is all just a nightmare
they wonder the Blair Witch kids is
having except the nightmare isn't
happening to them it's happening to the
rest of the world but it's scary the way
this is jittery boom scene
and they see Paranormal Activity fine
with me this time of year an actual
window opens up